everyone and uh welcome
so we'll start with item one apologies
for absence i have apologies from
councillors armitage
holmes
pickering
and brian wright are there any other
apologies
council barker
councillors uh barry
rouse and ridgeway
oh yes count yeah sorry councils barry
ridgeway
and rouse
thank you
any others
how's cupid thank you councillor
hutchinson
thank you item two declarations of
interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiar interest and or
other interests not already on their
register of interest in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time and i'm declaring
item 10 on the hra is a member of
richmond board
are there any other decorations
i'm on rick newport as well thank you
council ruff
councillor welton
same council liggett
no councillor clough
thank you
any others
no item three then minutes of the last
meeting to approve as a correct record
to sign the attachments of the council
meeting held on the 29th of november
have been circulated can we have a
proposal please
thank you council cupid seconded by
council powell all those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
well thank you they are carried
item 4 then chairman's announcements
you will all be aware of the devastating
news of the attack on former bowls over
chairman and consort ken and frieda
walker
ken was a member of the strategic
alliance committee between our two
authorities
and a keen advocate of the partnership
i have the privilege of knowing ken for
20 years
and i'm aware of his drive to make a
difference in his local community
both ken and frieda
were an excellent civic couple
those of you who knew them both
will say their love and care for each
other was evident
and frieda was the kindest person you
could wish to meet
her death is truly shocking
ken is still critically ill in hospital
i'm sure you'll all join me in sending
thoughts and prayers to ken
their family
and friends
but also join me
in a moment silence
in tribute to freda
thank you colleagues
i was saddened to learn of the sudden
death of joachim rupert
mayor of gross umstat
the town is in the land christ of
darmstadt dieberg
his untimely passing has taken a person
who had a positive vision for the
partnership between our two districts
i have conveyed our condolences to our
colleagues in germany
some of you will know that council of
william armitage had a heart attack
recently
there is nothing that can keep
counsellor armitage down let alone a
cardiac arrest
we all wish him a very speedy recovery
and look forward to hearing his dulcet
tones in due course
may i express sincere sympathies to
councillor steve pickering on the
passing of his wife
i am sure we are all in accord
that he has our full support at this
time
the 6th of february marks the 70th
anniversary of the accession of her
majesty the queen to the throne
jean and i will be representing north
east derbyshire to service of
commemoration at derby cathedral this
week
the council will surely recognize the
queen's devotion to duty and record of
selfless service to this country
the district will be joining with others
in sending our sincere congratulations
on reaching a significant milestone
in her reign and our nation's history
i will be attending a race night on the
18th of february at the shinon in north
wingfield in aid of my appeal for
ashgate hospice
the event has been organized by
councillor barry and is free to attend
the first race is at 8 pm so hopefully
you'll be able to come along
i am grateful to north wingfield parish
council who had a bucket collection for
my appeal at the switching on of their
christmas lights
i'm also appreciative of donations from
ashover parish council
along with sherland and hayam parish
council
sellout burns night was an outstanding
success
perhaps you will consider attending the
elvis night on the 12th of march
don't just talk about it
book tickets or as elvis would say
a little less conversation a little more
action please
i could have done worse
once again
thank you to colleagues
who are making a difference to support
my endeavors on behalf of the hospice
thank you
item five leaders announcements
councillor dale
thank you i'll just check everyone can
hear me okay before uh that long
yeah
okay thank you for that um
so i i'm conscious we have a busy agenda
today so i'm only gonna cover a few
fairly quick items uh hopefully so
firstly in relation to covid we have
seen a reduction recently um we had a
reduction of about 30 between last week
and the week before uh which is very
positive i think i'm sure we'll agree
although we have had a very slight
uptick in the past week probably uh
linked to the delayed impact
of schools returning
we're currently around 660 cases per 100
000
that's still very high for what we're
more used to
uh thinking about sort of the the the
summer onwards of last year cases were
usually uh significantly lower than that
so we are still high albeit the general
trend is is a downward one now which is
encouraging um with the lifting of plan
b restrictions we're still asking
residents though to be cautious to use
common sense
and clearly to take whatever measures
they feel comfortable with
uh to try and protect themselves and
reduce the spread
in terms of the impact on the council i
think we'll all be aware that sickness
and absence was high at the beginning of
the year
but it is largely uh back to normal now
um with one or two
with one or two cases
there was some significant pressure
within street scene
and refuse collection at the beginning
of the month
but i want to thank all staff for
working so hard to keep our essential
services going and with absolutely
minimal disruption to residents
in particular i want to thank paul
denton eddie owen jake johnson alex
hunter kieran smith ryan coupland steve
wright carl bolton charles haslam
steve ransom leon healed alan walker
paul gascoigne jamie harrison sean cross
ashley faith cliff hardy chris huntman
and portmatter and mark nuttall
who all went above and beyond by
volunteering to do refuge collection
shifts
to support the existing teams
this is a group sorry excuse me this is
a great example of the one team culture
within this council and it's incredibly
reassuring to know how flexible our
staff
are willing to be to the demands of the
organization and ready to pitch in and
to support one another and i'm sure i
speak on behalf of all councillors when
i say
a really big thank you to them
moving on i'm delighted that eckington
leisure centre has now reopened after
its 1.5 million pound transformation i
was really pleased to be able to go
and have a look just before christmas
when the finishing touches were being
made and it does look absolutely
fantastic
it was great to have an opportunity to
visit all of our leisure centres as well
as our street scene depot
and speaking to staff particularly in
the leisure centres there is a real buzz
around the levels of investment and
commitment to leisure uh by the council
at the moment particularly at a time
when many other councils are closing
them down
and in related news i'm really pleased
to inform members that last week cabinet
formally accepted a 1.4 million pound
grant
from the government's public sector
decarmenization scheme
to do a very similar improvements to
drumfield leisure center
the pool was relatively recently
refurbished and therefore won't be
affected but it is very welcome funding
and it will be help used to help reduce
the carbon impact on of the facility
uh in particular with the installation
of air source heat pumps
and solar panels on the roof uh together
with other internal improvements
it's not exactly clear yet when the
works will begin but obviously we're
hoping to do that as soon as possible
and it's hope that when they do the
disruption to service users will be
absolutely minimal so i'm sure everyone
will agree that so that's really good
news and very welcome funding to
to do some much needed improvements
there
i think most of the other items i wanted
to raise already on the agenda chair so
i will
leave it at that and allow us to move on
thank you very much
thank you so uh item six public
participation no questions have been
submitted under procedure rule nine
number eight sorry for this meeting so
we moved to item seven
which is um adoption of schedule three
of the local government miscellaneous
provisions act 1982 as amended and the
sex establishment policy so council dale
thank you chair so it's back to me uh
the as the report makes clear our
general licensing committee uh results
are referred this massive council so
that we can adopt the relevant
legislation and policies to give the
authority the power uh to control the
number and the location of sex
establishments
within the district uh the draft
draft policy before us today has been to
the committee on two separate occasions
as well as through a 13-week public
consultation last year um as far as can
be achieved the views of respondents
have been taken into account uh in the
in the revised draft that's before us
today
um it's noted that there there is strong
opposition to any establishments being
set up within the district
but we do need this policy
in place in order to be able to regulate
regulate them should they
uh they arise um i think it's fairly
straightforward and procedural hopefully
all members have had a chance to uh to
read through the policy um excuse the
pun but there's nothing uh sexy at all
about this policy so i'm happy to uh
move the recommendations thank you chair
well actually you can't move them you're
not present in the meeting
so do we have to propose the uh thank
you council liggett and do we have a
a seconder
thank you gomez councillor gomez renee
do we have any comments or questions
council cornwell
i didn't know we were allowed to partake
if we weren't if we were on zoom have i
misunderstood some new rule
no there's no new rule alex dale has
partake twice already
in the meeting and i didn't think the
regulations were the if we were on zoom
we were allowed to partake in the
meeting
has there been another change i'm just
going to turn to the monitoring officer
the rules haven't changed the rules are
that you're not counted as being present
for the purposes of section 85 the
six-month rule and that you cannot move
or second or vote on an item whether you
can speak is at the discretion of the
chair
and the rule that hasn't changed is
could you stay here could you stand when
you're addressing the meeting as well
please
so we any comments or questions about
the report council shipment
yeah we could ask you to stand please
[Music]
thank you chair um there's just a few
things actually uh from reading through
the document i got i get the impression
like it's it's been created to stop
these sorts of establishments come into
the district
because if you look at the sorts of
places where we're saying they are not
allowed
the only place i've
come to realize that we can actually
have one he's probably in the middle of
a forest somewhere
um and i think that
by doing that we're actually shooting
ourselves in the foot because when it
could when we get challenged on the fact
that we're not giving people sufficient
and appropriate places to have them
you know we're leaving ourselves open
for that challenge and i think that we
need to actually look at like i'd like
the leaders to explain where he thinks
we could have one where does he believe
it is a good place to have an
establishment like this that's the
policy is trying to regulate um but i
would also like to if possible
to make a
an amendment to the motion
to change a few things in the policy
itself
because in
a policy like this the main aim of it
should be to reduce harm for the
employees that work in them and any
customers or clients that they have
going to them and actually i did a word
search on this whole policy and it
doesn't even use the word harm and
reduce harm at all
and i think that in the
current in 1.1 paragraph three i think
we need to in search reducing harm after
the word seeking two
because that to me is what the policy
should be about
um
and where it says
appendix b
20
it says um
that
the door staff or any security should be
no more than five meters away from
somebody i think that needs to be
changed to no more than say five seconds
away because if there's obstacles in the
way between
uh
someone that's trying to police these
establishments
take longer than you know 20 seconds if
there's people that are there in the way
tables cupboards whatever it might be
and i think that that wording needs to
change to five seconds rather than five
meters
um and in point 22
um
of the same section of appendix b
it should read that rather than it being
single sex
toilets i think it needs to be changed
to
um single cubicles slash rooms that are
unisex toilets so we're not restricting
what the establishments can do
in terms of people using the restrooms
um because that just makes more sense to
me why would you prescribe it to be
single sex and allow multiple people to
win because that assumes that let's say
women don't attack women in uh toilets
or men don't attack men in toilets which
is obviously a bizarre
thing to
assert because that does happen so i
think we actually just need to tidy the
policy upon these few things
um
as part of my amendment if that's okay
chair
it's
it's not a
emotion counselor shipment
so but you're asking for inclusions or
amendments to the policy
i'm asking for the motion that some of
the recommendations are on the table to
be amended
and add that the
amendments i've just read out are
included in the policy that is possible
but there isn't there isn't emotion
there isn't a motion on the table it's a
report with recommendations
that is the motion though
the motion is that we accept the
recommendations
counselor
uh thank you chair and what i would like
to say this is one more example yet
again where the work should be done in
committee you'll find all those working
in committee to make changes to policies
like this no no let me speak
we make we make those adjustments in
committee and we all have that input
they get made there then they get
brought here what you're doing is you're
making a grandstand again at council
rather than working in committee
everybody knows that one more time
thank you chair
so you've made it so you've made a
proposal so you need a second accountant
councillor hancock are you wishing to
speak now council hancock i'll reserve
the right chair thank you
so any comments or questions about the
proposed motion which has been seconded
thank you i can share the meeting
council hall without your help
then
council barker
oh thank you chair uh
i am a bit confused with this i i tend
to agree with
council of foster a bit
this is not the place it's a big
policy that to start just adding bits
and taking bits away i'm not
i don't feel as though this is the right
place
to be doing that um
well it is it might be changing the
whole
concept of you just i was traveling
through donna fine with which picture
you're on about so i'm not entirely
clear it might change a full paragraph
to some of the that
i don't agree with so
i don't know as
i'm looking for assistance really is
there any way you're sort of
referring back and looking at those
proposals
that that is it agent because today i
suppose
we've got council kenyan and then i've
got councillor renick and then council
reader and i can see councillor dale on
screen thank you
thank you chad um yes i don't think we
should be amending at this stage for the
reasons councillor mark has just given
just for example the five meters five
second change
there's not just a
reaction time but also visibility of
what's going on and uh you know i'm not
saying bouncers are 100 meter runners
but
five seconds could be 40 meters which uh
changes completely the intent of that so
i think this is not the right place to
change it if people want to change it
bring up a review of the policy and
submit a revised policy at some time in
the future thank you jeff
council renick
yeah same same chair um i think but we
rely on these
policy groups with officers input to
make sure these are right within law
within parameters i'm not an expert at
five minutes five seconds whether it's
appropriate i can't you might you might
be right but i don't know i don't want
to take your word for it i want to take
somebody who knows what they're talking
about
can't read it
thank you chad
i was part of the committee that you
know talked about this and we i felt we
we really did take account of all the
information that we had to hand at the
time
um you know we had um kevin is it kevin
schiller charlotte that was in there
with us we were able to ask him
questions about all the legals ins and
outs of it and i felt we did quite a lot
of work as part of that committee to to
satisfy ourselves
with the policy itself i i think it does
go far enough and covers that all those
questions were asked at that committee
about harm
and you know so i do feel that we should
just move it along that's my opinion
thank you council dale
thank you chair um yeah generally
speaking agree with all the comments
that have been made there's been ample
opportunity a full 13-week consultation
uh you know various iterations of this
draft so through committee there's an
ample opportunity to to make these sorts
of changes as with all policies it will
be reviewed at some stage in the future
and that gives
any councillors opportunity to suggest
any amendments as to the question that
the council shipment asked me directly i
mean uh the policy doesn't restrict
numerical numerically or by location the
number of any sex establishments but he
asked me so on a personal basis i would
say that i don't i don't particularly
feel there are any appropriate locations
i think the better location will be
in a more built up area um but obviously
we need to have a policy in place
uh to be able to guide decision making
on this and that that's what this is all
about so i'd support the adoption of
this policy today
and if there are further tweets or
suggestions that they want to make
changes then then do that as part of a
policy review at a later stage thank you
chair
any other comments
council hancock coming to you for
your right of replying
thank you chair i i think it it does
kind of highlight sometimes the problems
we have when reports come to committee
and they are very abridged i mean we're
going to have this problem later on as
well i think
um it clearly doesn't have as as council
readers says obviously discussions were
had during committee but this is not
necessarily reflective of all of those
things that were considered and that
perhaps is a failing in the way that we
are getting reports presented um
i i do think
i do agree with what council shipment
says i i'm happy to to second this and i
but i also take on board and i'm not
sure if it was castlevania council
kenyan so apologies to two but i do
think there was a very valid point
raised that actually there perhaps does
need to be a provision for both distance
and time because time is critical but
yes things also need to be with
invisibility so it may be a case that
there does need to be a reference back
rather than rather than necessarily a
case of adopting anything with
amendments today um
but i do think there's definitely a
learning a learning point um in terms of
how things are presented to council on
the year
council shipment your right to reply
thank you chair um
like council i've got such a challenge
there's certain points that were raised
in committee the council fosters this
all the time well they should have
raised the committee it should have been
rated we should have done this in
committee we are the decision maker in
this council and if you like keep
passing things around and committees are
all weak but we are the decision maker
if we want to amend a policy for this
council we can do it here we don't need
to keep passing it around committees and
when it's our raised in committee
they're not always included in the final
policy as we've found out because
council bangkok did raise the uh the
five meter thinking committee and again
it's still in there so to say that
somehow they're not being fed into
committee is absolute nonsense so i
don't understand why you get up and say
it because you know it's lies but you
carry on saying it anyway i think what
we need to do is if it's possible chair
if we can
have a look at have a look at the things
i've suggested and perhaps try and tie
them in if they're legally appropriate
or if we can make you know we can
tighten the policy up perhaps officers
can look at this after this committee
obviously we do need to adopt the policy
i'm not saying we should reject the
policy i was just trying to improve it
at full council where we make the
decision on what the policy ultimately
looks like
point of order chair isn't the words you
know it's lies a breach of our code of
conduct
not if it's true
as i said before you know comments like
lies and things probably not the most
helpful words to be using in debate but
i prefer not to have
of
any opinions of that nature banded
around whether you think it's true or
not
and
in response to your comments council
shipment um i'm not preempting the
decision of um where your the vote might
be on your amendment let's just imagine
it was lost
i'm sure the suggestions you've raised
can be taken into account by officers
and when the policy is reviewed those
those them considerations can be taken
at that point i'm sure that would be
a way of
having your feedback taken seriously
so it's been moved and seconded that
those amendments are included
all those in favor of the amendment
all those against
any abstentions
so the amendments are lost
then we come to the substantive
recommendations that have been proposed
and seconded
so are there any final comments or
questions about those recommendations
if not then we get we move to the vote
on the recommendations all those in
favor
any against
any abstentions
those are carried thank you
item eight the annual audit report over
to you police council parking
thank you very much chair
um so i've got four items on the agenda
today so i'll be fairly brief and i'd
like to present the annual audit letter
in respect of
2020 and 2021 from the council's
external auditor mazars for the council
to
no
azares presented their audit findings to
the audit committee on the 30th of
september and issued an unqualified
audit option opinion sorry on the
financial statements on the 30th of
november
i'll plan it back to youtube
thank you and we'll come to proposing
and seconding shortly so it gives an
opportunity for comments or questions
are there any
i think it was given a rigorous
discussion it to finance an order
so you proposing council parking i
recommend to move yes and i second
all those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
thank you that's carried
item nine then the invitation to become
an opted body for external ordinate
appointments so would you please count a
parking
uh thank you very much chair
once again um the purpose of this report
is to request the approval of council to
accept the public sector audit
appointment or psaa from here on because
it's a mouthful uh invitation to become
adopted in authority for the appointment
of external auditors which happens
typically every five years and this is
uh
due in april 2023 or to commence in
april 2023
psaa are the current appointing person
for local authority audits and have been
confirmed
as continuing the role of appointing
person for the next period which
commences
at april 2023 as previously psaa have
invited
eligible bodies to opt into their
national scheme for auditor appointments
ahead of a procurement process
finalizing appointments before the
required deadline of the 31st of
december 2022
the council opted into the national
scheme in 2016
and the benefits of opting into the
national scheme remain and these are
laid out at
1.3 in the report
and
opting into the
national scheme
provides a
sector-led collaborative approach
offering the best value for money
and assuring independence of the auditor
appointment
not using the national scheme would
require
a local procurement exercise which would
not benefit from the economies of scale
of the national procurement exercise
thank you are there any comments or
questions
again it was considered a finance and
nordic committee
so we're moving to
the proposal please council parking
thank you chair uh i recommend
to do this
that the council accept the public
sector audit appointments invitation to
opt into the national scheme for the
appointment of external auditors for
five consecutive financial years
commencing april 2023
thank you nice second we got value for
money there you read the whole
recommendation out so thank you all
those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
that's carried thank you very much and
and item 10 the medium term financial
plan and the hr our a bit we'll have to
deal with separately
so we'll we'll go to bit without the hr
a bit first council parking
thank you chair
so uh today i'm presenting the
medium-term financial plan which
encompasses the current year's budget
the original budget for
2022 slash 23 and the planning budgets
for the following three years to
2025-6
in 2019 i inherited
a two million pound budget gap left by
the previous administration
today i'm again able to present to
council a balanced budget for the
upcoming financial year
this is the third year running that
we've done so
and two and two of these years we were
in unprecedented times of a global
pandemic hopefully that will soon be
over
um but
the diligence and the
uh progress that we have made in the
finance arena is specifically
and
very deliberately recognized by me
uh as a in large part the excellent work
of our section 151 officer jane dethick
and her excellent team
who are ever vigilant and committed to
keeping the council finances firmly on
track
i will present the budget in more detail
in due course but first i want to
provide an update on the national
settlement for next year
the secretary of state in his letter to
council leaders in december recognized
the vital role that councils play within
local communities
and never
more so than during the pandemic
the government's priority in this
settlement is to provide
stability in the intermediate term this
means
much of last year's settlement has been
rolled over
as in previous years
this includes the new homes bonus
which was hugely welcome news to us
uh with a windfall payment of 609 000
pounds
the lower tier services grant has also
been retained
and our allocation is 126 000 pounds
and finally in recognition of the wide
range of additional services provided by
local councils to the community
a one-off services grant has been
introduced
and our award from that is 193 000
pounds
um
the government plans to consult over the
next year
on updating the funding system
and have for the first time confirmed
that there will be
transitional protections
to accompany any funding reforms
this is important as
it helps to dampen the impact of the
reform and provides us with some time to
review and adapt our own plans
we were pleased that the secretary of
state recognized this the
work this council does in the local
community and comforted by the stability
award afforded for next year
but this is a one-year settlement so
forecasting for 2023 onwards remains
challenging until we know more about the
funding reforms proposed
so now i will present the general fund
budget
covet is still impacting a little but
much less than last year some services
are recovering from loss of income
compared to
pandemic levels but it's pleasing to
note that they continue to improve
i'll draw your attention now to the
table one on page 100 of your packs
which summarizes the financial
good progress is being made
towards securing future years savings
ahead of schedule
contrast this with the mtfp in 2019 and
you'll see that the two million pound
hole left by the previous administration
is reduced significantly
a strong and effective culture of
financial management sits
right across this council maintaining
momentum on identifying and implementing
savings
uh and and it's key to this financial
management is identifying those savings
it's endemic within our organization now
the summary of the council's efficiency
plan at appendix 3
page 104 should you be following
uh summarises our
planning and commitment to retain a
financial
a balanced financial plan
the efficiency plan isn't exactly new
this has this work has been and will
continue to be undertaken by the
council's senior management team
working collaboratively
collaboratively
with the leadership
uh
monitoring and reporting on progress is
important to us and as such progress
against this plan will form part of the
financial monitoring that is already
scrutinized by the cabinet and audit
committee thank you
each quarter
appendix 3 is a summary
the detailed working document is a
living plan
owned as i said previously by senior
management
uh by the senior management team and
leadership you'll note that within each
category
are initiatives and behind each
initiative are numerous projects and
plans i'll give you one for example
uh don't overburden anybody
digital transformation so
not a new initiative but new ideas are
coming forward from this initiative all
the time
covid has taught us the importance of
digital services to our community and we
plan to keep responding to this
currently planned digitization projects
include looking at better ways to
process applications in the revenues
team
better integer integration of
information in legal services
and a move from paper-based systems in a
number of services including land
charges
i trust that you will be reassured by
these plans
i certainly am and i'm confident that
they will be delivered
moving on to council tax
we are aware and completely understand
the pressures of our on our residents
household budgets
council tax setting is always a
difficult decision
this council faces the same costs and
inflationary pressures as any other
organization
we want to keep delivering high quality
services our residents have benefited
from since 2019 so this year
we are recommending to council
a below inflation rise of two point five
eight percent
which equals ten pence per week
uh for the average band the household
yeah
uh and finally the general fund capital
program is relatively static at the time
at the current time with no major
changes to reports right now
yeah thank you you're just coming to the
end of your time there council parking
and so you're moving the recommendations
from one to six
do you have a seconder for those thank
you council cupid
are there any comments or questions
about the general fund from
recommendations one to six council
hancock
thank you chair um
i would thank council parking for the
report but several months ago actually
we did ask for a little bit more
detailed report in terms of what was on
here and
rather than say that you don't want to
overburden as i would rather be
overburdened and go through the details
so i actually know what i'm looking at
and know what i'm voting for because
there's still lots of
anticipateds and
hopefully we can do this in headline
stuff but no actual detail behind it
um
so the reality is i am disappointed and
yes we're delivering the balanced budget
but the reality is we're delivering
balance budget by pulling pretty much
everything we've got out of reserves
um based on based on this so
i i'm concerned with it um
we know that households are going to be
under pressure we don't know what the
impact is going to be on the revenues we
generate through the leisure centres and
such like that because those are luxury
items that are likely to go as cost of
living increases so
i i'm concerned at the robustness of the
estimates that have been used but we do
need more detail than what we've got
here considering them also
thank you castle barker
thank you
thank you chad
yeah let's go over to that but uh
i think we have had a good year and i
reckon what you said about uh
the finance team i think they've done a
great job they work really hard and uh
there's obviously every year under
pressure we central government cutting
back but i think we've had a good year
this year we've had a bit of a
extra monies as you listed from the new
old bonus one or two other things that's
come forward
uh and
like you say
uh it is a we cost a living going up one
thing or another
uh
other councils
police authority wherever they're going
to put their
precepts up
uh i think we can afford not to pull it
up this month this year
uh we have still got some in reserves
and we're tapping into that regularly
uh i will take exception to that 2
million pound funding gap i'm not quite
sure where you got that one from but uh
we
there always been the prospect of it
being two million feather damn but i
don't think we left you we won but
anyway that's
we can argue about that somewhere else
uh
but so we we're
if we're just voting on it one at a time
uh we we're not in support of the
putting that council tax for
five quid
at this point in time i think we can
manage without you
any other comments or questions council
shipment
thank you chair um
yeah we have this in audit um and i
asked the same question there well
where's all the detail because the
council of parking stood in this chamber
when was it six months ago eight months
ago promised us to be here in january
this is solid plans it's looking at me
like i'm talking a foreign language but
you were stood in this chamber promising
us that you'd call me some solid plans
and telling us how this money
would be
balanced in future because although
there might be a balanced budget this
year
the next few years don't look that up
right and i think that if you can't come
with any serious plans i wonder if you
expect us to vote for it we're not sat
talking to the finance team like you are
every day we're we're
basically voting on what you're telling
us and what you're telling us today
there's no way i can support what you've
just come out with because you're
kicking the can down the road and you've
not come forward with any real plans
so how on earth can we support it
any other comments or questions
i'm going to ask
no i'm i'm going to uh use my discretion
not to take any from the screen
and so i'm just going to come to a
council bar parking
thank you chair uh yes councillor barker
the uh you're right about the two
billion pound hole as i said it's in the
mtfp yeah uh and it was at that time uh
however you're right you didn't leave us
with a two million pound hole in the
account
but it was a two million pound in the in
the mtfp yeah
so
uh and um
and for councillor hancock i believe it
was um yeah i i did say that we bring
the uh i did say that we bring an action
plan to the to the uh council which is
what we've done the you it's important
to understand though that the senior
management
team are the owners of that plan and
that can change at any time it's it's
the senior management
so i'll leave you there chair
thank you it has been moving second did
it so we we do need to come to a
recorded vote for this because it's a
financial item so i'm going to hand over
to monitoring officer
thank you chair i will read your name
can you please tell me if you're for
against or abstaining
councillor p wright
council wheelhouse
council welton
councillor thacker
councillor tate
cancer stone
councillor stratford stevenson
council shipman against cancer rough
four councillor rowe
council renwick
council reader
abstain
councillor powell
councillor potts
council platts
council parkin
councillor morley
counselor lily
what would you like me to do about
recording your vote
i'm i'm i'm afraid i've got to abstain
because i can't do the debate okay we
need to talk about this chair because
we need some discipline and using this
stuff
okay thank you councillor liggett
for
councillor lewis
council lacey
councillor kerry
councillor kenyon
councillor jones
oh she's on the screen thank you
council house hartsworn
against
cancer hancock against council hall
councillor gomezrini
council finale
councillor mark foster
councillor emmons
councillor elliott
councillor dayton
council cupid
council cornwall
against
councillor cooper
council club
council birkin
abstain
council barca again
and councillor and cliff is not here
thank you the results are 25 votes for
eight against and five abstain
abstentions so
one to six are carried
um so those now involved with wrigle
will need to leave for the housing
revenue account section and so we'll
nominations for
chair for the hra part of it
you can't have a cabinet member there's
chair
council mark has nominated himself
i'll second that we've got a seconder so
we have a nomination for council lewis
um
right so we've got two people yeah we've
got to vote for it all all those in
favor of council barker
all those against
all those in favor of council lewis
all those against
council lewis is carried the chair is
yours
now
well thank you everyone um
oh the power
right
um so yes the next fight and then is the
housing revenue um account
so
speaking on this particular item
that's parking
ah yet again
and so
there are no major changes to report in
the hra we are recommending to council
that rents increase in line with
government guidance as this council has
done for many years
which is 4.1 this year the
rhl management fee has been renegotiated
in line with the requirements of the new
agreement
and will be 9.75 million pounds for next
year
the hra capital programme includes an
additional allocation again this year
for further modernization and eco works
on the non-traditional housing stock
back to you
and and yeah i will move the
recommendations 7 to 30. thank you very
much indeed councillor parking we have
those recommendations moved we have a
secondary councillor cupid
i think we now open it up to uh any
discussion any questions
council barca
thank you chair uh again it's i know
we're tied into this uh
a social housing rent standard um
and we're looking at four point one
percent increase which
no matter how you look at it that that's
on top of everything else so we've just
spoke about that's a lot of money to a
lot of people
uh
i think that we we ought to be at least
challenging that standard
uh because that could keep going up i
mean when we were in control it actually
made it we had to reduce rents which
created another problem
so it's i'm not quite sure whether
that's a good
standard or how it's calculated or who
tells you where it is
so i personally uh on top of everything
else
uh i i can't vote for that and i know it
it's something we've got to do but i
agree with most others all the other
stuff about rick northern how much money
well uh i'd personally when i'm staying
just on that one because 4.1
there's no saying where it could be next
year
uh and it's it's just cons well i don't
think we can that's the
the legalities
is that if we tied into that then i
think that's what it comes out at but
i think we should challenge that that's
what my
record
thank you very much indeed councillor
barker councillor parking you want to
come back on that
okay counselorship thank you chair um i
totally agree with what council black
has just said i think we kind of
mentioned i think if we remove 0.8
and replace it with take ourselves out
of the social housing rent standard
then i would vote for it but by leaving
that in there i think that's a massive
increase for people that are going to be
on some of the lowest incomes in this
district
okay thank you very much cancer shipping
council parking
uh thank you chair
yes
it is a large amount and i i don't
disagree with that however you have to
remember that
ricknor like every other body
has to
live in the current economy
and
they have they their costs are set to
rise and that's what the standard has
recognized okay so that's why it is 4.1
cpi plus 1.1
that's why it is that this year
okay
so i like you i am extremely concerned
about people
and the affordability of these rents
uh it's not something that that we do
lightly
but we are aware that if we
don't accept this recommendation it's
highly likely that
the rigor will get into difficulties
during the following year
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed any further
comments or questions
so do you have a second
okay
so we have to deal with that one uh
first
and it's a recorded vote um
so over to mr sternberg
thank you chair
as before i'll read your name
please tell me whether you're for
against or abstaining in relation to the
amendment
council right
against council wheelhouse
hence
councillor tate
councillor stone
councillor stratford stevenson
council shipment
four councillor
council renick
cancer reader
for
council powell
council pots council platz
council parking
council morley
council lilly
four
councillor liggett against councillor
lewis
against council lacey
councillor kerry
councillor kenyon
council hearts horn
councillor hancock four councillor hall
councillor gomezrini
councillor for now
councilman mark foster
cancer emmons
council elliot
councillor dayton
councillor cupid
council cornwall
four
councillor cooper
council burkin four
council barca four
thank you very much indeed so the uh
amendment has been lost 13 to 20 with
one abstention
i mean move to the uh to the main
recommendations sternberg if you would
thank you chair council right for
council wheelhouse
council tate
cancer stone
abstain thank you
council stratfor stevenson
council shipman
against
row
four
council renick
cancer reader
abstain
cancer pal
council pots
council plats
council pickering
he's not here
council parking
council morley
council lily
abstain counselor liggett for
councillor lewis
four councillor lacey
councillor kerry
councillor kenyan
cancer hearts horn against
council hancock
against council hall
councillor gomez rini
council for now
councilor mark foster
council emmons
cancer elliot
councillor dayton
council cupid
councillor cornwall
against
cancer cooper
council burkin abstain
council barker abstain
and can't um
and the motion is carried 19
with eight abstentions and seven against
thank you very much indeed and we can
bring back in the folks and uh thank you
for your forbearance that was rather fun
thank you so uh item 11 treasury
strategy report
back to you council parking
surprise surprise thank you chair um the
purpose of this report is to provide
council with the necessary information
to approve the suite of treasury
strategies for the period
2021-22 to 2024-25
these strategies are compliant with both
the sip code for treasury management and
mhclg's
investment guidance
of 2018
this week comprises of three strategies
treasury management strategy which
provides the
framework for managing the council's
cash flows borrowing and investments for
the period
the capital strategy which is intended
to provide a high level concise overview
of how capital expenditure capital
financing and treasury management
activity contribute to the provision of
the council services
and the investment strategy which
focuses on investments made for
service purposes and commercial reasons
rather than those made for treasury
management
all three strategies have been appended
to the report for members consideration
uh and i'll move the recommendations uh
that back to you jeff thank you for have
a second
thank you council cupid any comments or
questions
counselor hancock
thank you chair and uh thank you
councillor parking my question to be
truthful overall on this because again
we've got some significant bits missing
particularly on the investment strategy
and i apologize if it's here and i've
missed it but i have been through
several times we've obviously got the
jvc
um and the situation around the industry
that they're in has changed considerably
over the last 12 months construction
costs have shot through the roof
and obviously as we feel
well it's going to be the biggest pinch
on cost of living in a generation
power spanx is also going to go down and
i think it's important that that we've
got some sort of information
on how that is going to affect our
investment in that um and as i say it
seems to be missing from here altogether
so i'd appreciate if you could update us
on on what's happening there please
other comments or questions
council parking to reply
thank you chair um
i'm not really in the business of uh
making those kind of predictions but we
do have to
uh
make guidance and
make certain assumptions however
the
the
rate of sales of houses is is not one
that i'm
expertly
equipped
to be able to answer and uh with respect
i think uh
it would be very difficult to predict
that at this point in time there are
some assumptions that we could make
however they are no more than that
assumptions
okay if there's further detail
that uh that is required then
please feel free to ask it to target
committee when you get the next
opportunity
thank you it's been moving second in all
those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
it's been carried thank you
so much to item 12 questions from
members asked under procedure rule 9.2
we have one question from council barker
to councillor powell or would you please
council barker
uh there you go can i ask when
if and when will a car parking strategy
for the whole district be produced thank
you
that took too long
um council powell
thank you chair
um when i saw council marcus question i
thought there was a very quick answer
um and i thought there was a medium
length answer
and there was a very long and boring
answer and i was going to ask you which
one you wanted but i won't
um the very quick answer is it's not if
um and when
um it actually went to cabinet last week
but
can i thank you for your question
because it does give me an opportunity
to
update the council on our evolving
policies and parking strategies
uh most members will know that when many
of our mostly non-trad housing
estates were built in the post-war
period
car ownership was
extremely limited in some cases zero
as a result at that time little or no
provision was made for parking
and not a lot has happened since
there was a recent scrutiny review of
residential parking
and found of course as we all know as
members
it's a district-wide issue
and i think all our email inboxes will
have
parking things in them
um but that review did coincide with
work on a strategy to address
those problems
as i said last week the government
approved a strategy which sets out how
we intend to improve parking across the
district going forward
but i must add in all honesty
that because of the scale of the
challenge this will take a number of
years to actually implement
however
we did feel that a start had to be made
and so we've earmarked 288 000 pounds
annually
funded by the housing revenue account
and as you all know that can only be
used on hra land and assets
the approach means that uh locations we
continue to be in the most need
which usually go inside of where we as a
council have land available and where we
have a high proportion of property we
own
so using that criteria we have
identified four sites five sites in the
district
um and
work is
ongoing and in some cases that's an
advanced stage to get those underway
uh from that initial annual budget
we had some surplus funds
so we're going to carry out a trial of
grass protection surfacing
this trial will allow us to assess the
viability of a
potentially more cost-effective solution
which may lead
to being able to provide
parking in more locations
in a shorter space of time and more cost
effectively
um you will find a lot of detail in the
cabinet papers um
but the scrutiny review also looked at
um
some areas that they thought
needed to be looked at uh one of those
has come through at appadole
where we are doing a considerable amount
of work it's already been through
planning
waiting for some decisions from highways
at dcc
um and funding is available for it
um so that's the sort of medium
answer
councilor barker thank you thank you
chet
thank you council powell um council mark
do you have a supplementary question
arising from that
and over to you thank you
i have read
all the uh the cabinet reports and the
various papers
so
i was aware of that
uh
but
the question to me and i'd say there's
there's rationales and criteria for
picking the various schemes that are in
the pipeline
uh but i'm still not clear how up and
all that's going to top of that list uh
as it's recognized in the papers and
you've just said it every village stroke
estate has got issues with parking
everyone
therefore i'd like to see a full list
it's only a partial one
of all that so all members not not just
us
these issues all around village
market are you are you asking the
question
of a speech developing here
but i'm nearly there
be quick
well we report back to all his residents
whether it's that phone lane ducting
grassmore
eckington clay cross so we're not to
know where we are on that list however
my specific question
can you explain to me the rationale for
spending 125 000 pounds of hra money on
40 parking spaces in ethanol
when it already has provisions for 18
places and there are only 45 properties
managed by wrigley
and i just hope
it's not because it has a lovely view
down a dale that's that's that's upon
that
so
can you answer me that because i'm still
confused right now
council power to reply
um i regret your confusion counselor
parker
and uh that was quite clever though
looking down the dale thank you
i wonder
wondered when that would come up to be
honest um
and i did anticipate it might be today
um
right up no how did that begin well
let's go back to the scrutiny review
uh
in which they identified three areas
at that point the process was being
managed by ricknall homes
and they
um
said they wanted to look at three areas
only northside kelstedge and door
and
for various reasons
um the holy moorside one after
consultation
um was put on hold
the cell stage one uh kovid interfered i
don't want to make that an excuse but it
did interfere and that will probably be
on the list
for next year
and that left up a no
and if you actually look at the figures
the amount per parking space at
happening is no greater than anywhere
else
and as i say that i i will stand by it
but it was a written initiative
which was then carried forward when we
did the strategy
thank you
thank you council powell
thank you council banker
so move to item 13 to consider motions
from members under procedure rule number
10 and the first one is a motion
submitted by councillor shipman
thank you chair um
i'm hoping this is something we can all
agree on seeing as every single leader
in the viper meetings has acknowledged
that this needs to happen so fingers
crossed there will be a consensus on
this issue but i think remote meetings
need to happen let's let's face it here
you know we've got people side home who
can't partake in this meeting including
the leader of the council here
and it's just unacceptable it would be
more efficient if we could all do it
from home because we've all got jobs
we've got kids we've got you know people
we need to care for
et cetera and i think we seriously need
to be pushing this as a district council
that you know
we're at the spearhead of this movement
because we need to have remote or hybrid
meetings and i'm not saying it's
prescriptive but
the option needs to be there for
district councils to hold remote rabbi
meetings because we just can't have this
you know we can't have this these
discussions where we're going we need to
reduce the amount of councils coming in
every single one of us 53 councils that
are elected to this chamber deserve to
be here representing their communities
and i think it's just totally
unacceptable that we have people sat at
home that can't vote on behalf of their
residents so seriously we can all come
together behind this motion and just
let's start pushing it forward properly
do you have a seconder
chelsea hancock
i'll reserve the right to speak please
chair thank you
any comments or questions
uh
council lily
yeah
i'm coming from this at different angles
here
and this is one of the reasons why i'm
sat down because basically one of the
discipline disciplines are because
people are not actually close enough to
the microphone i can't hear so i'm using
this as a demonstration yeah
all i'm suggesting is i'm going to
support this motion simply because it
puts another
club in the bag
because when i turned up here today i
didn't know whether i'd be able to hear
or not
yeah
the last time i came in here we just got
half of this and it was just a small
committee meeting and i could make the
reasonable adjustments to be able to
hear what was going on
today no matter how i've tried with this
machine with these machines and whatever
else
the discipline is not there it needs to
be it needs to be worked on
and put in but
if that is not forthcoming
by the next council meeting i will be
looking to try and get what this is
suggesting
reasonable adjustment for my disability
and i'm not just talking about for me
i'm talking about anybody else because
what the last meeting i went to
in the
uh
in the
leisure center
there were people with so-called perfect
hearing that couldn't hear
and no reasonable adjustment was made so
i'm going to support this motion to try
and promote reasonable adjustment for
people like myself that i've got a
hearing difficulty endless
thank you council lily and i think given
your comments i think
for the remainder of the the meeting i'm
sure people will not mind if i say that
we'll remain seated to make sure that
you
you are hearing the microphone clearly
um
council cupid and then i'll come to
council birkin
thank you chair thanks for allowing me
to remain seated um i think we do all
agree on on the principles behind this
motion uh that it's beneficial for
councils to be able to run virtual or
hybrid meetings even if that sometimes
proposes poses challenges i think we've
seen today and in previous months um but
we do need to always balance that
because sometimes they are better in
person and i do welcome has been back in
the chamber i think whenever possible
and recognising uh reasons that members
have i think we all know that the
government did consult on this and we're
awaiting the outcomes and hopefully
for them to pursue this legislation as
soon as possible and as far as i
understand it they are supportive of it
um in terms of lobbying this council and
i know councillor dale as leader have
been pushing forward uh sort of
accelerating the government to get that
through
uh in terms of the lga uh dcn and also
raising it directly with ministers and
councillor dale uh has done that as well
as i think officers uh of the council
um so i think given that we're already
doing it i'm not sure there's a lot to
be gained by writing another letter to
the secretary of state so i can't
support motion personally but i do agree
with the principles and i know that like
myself councillor dale and i'm sure all
members will continue to lobby the
government to introduce this as soon as
possible
thank you and council birkin
thank you chair yeah i completely agree
with the council shipments proposal here
uh i think it goes without saying that
we need to make the availability for all
members to take part in in meetings and
we've seen because of covid um
that
we are we have been able to sort of
manage with remote meetings uh i think
i'd agree with council cupid that maybe
hybrid meetings are the best i'm sad
that she doesn't want to write to the
government um i would have thought that
uh
mr johnson would appreciate the letter
from uh from our area uh to
distract him into something else
uh
i agree with uh with chancellor lilly as
well but my other point that i'm making
is i am classed as
i'm not sure if it's extremely or
certainly um
clinically vulnerable
so whether i should be here or not is
another point i've not told my wife but
there we go
uh but also i'm very grateful to you
let's sit down as well because i haven't
i have a
mobility problem i had a spinal injury
some years ago and getting into the
council is not easy sometimes
uh most of our colleagues uh from both
sides of the of this uh committee
this council who are at home i think
have got some some one-on-one our other
medical problem
and i think by having this sort of
opportunity continued for councils would
enable as i said before everyone to be
able to take part
uh if i'm
not mistaken the government is able to
have proxy votes i think it was
um and they've continued that without
any uh change whatsoever with that
whilst denying the opportunity for
members in lower lower level council
low-level meetings uh to be able to
share in the same sort of opportunities
so i already endorse the council
shouldn't he put anything thank you
chair
thank you council birkin and um
obviously not trying to start a
precedent today but i just thought it
was best while council lily had raised
an issue that we do some of us who've
been on council a long time i've been a
council 20 years now we know that the
rule of debate is to stand and speak
um and that's the same the length and
breadth of the country but i think maybe
we need to think about what's right for
north east derbyshire and our members so
maybe that's something for governance
but that's
something for another day but i think
the comments we're hearing uh
are very important so katarinik
yeah sorry chair i i
struggling to understand why we do have
to stand it is a bit awkward in this
room it was awkward before these small
tables you're half standing up half
bending over trying to read your stuff
you all sit down so i completely agree
we should be all sitting down it's easy
to get to your microphone
but more importantly than that that's
just a one-off while other opportunity
is that ever since i've been in this um
to these meetings
council lilly has complained about his
access to hearing this meeting and i
can't i i'm fed up of actually nothing
being done about this it's absolutely
appalling that we have not found a
solution to council lilly's problem i
don't care what it costs but i'm sure
there's technology
that to actually help him to hear this
meeting properly and
i'll be disappointed if we don't find a
solution very soon it's it's it's
painful to listen every month
to him complain he can't hear this is
not addressing his needs and i've yet to
find out what solutions he needs and why
we haven't addressed it
council mark foster
uh thank you chair yeah uh
i was going to say much the same thing
for council about council lilly but i
think uh uh
councillor venice said it much much
better than i could but as to the actual
motion itself uh something that i don't
make any sense of it talks about the
government uh couldn't advise government
advice to no longer asking people to
work from home in england and scotland
wales and northern ireland is different
but here
here we've got residents and the public
been asked to turn up for work now for
myself my own view is that we should be
doing exactly the same i know there's
difficulties and other things we have to
get around i know there's difficulties
when we went to keller marsh sports
center it was very difficult to hear
people i struggled myself and my aim is
okay so i know there's difficulties we
can work around but for actually turning
up i believe myself that we should be
turning up like the residents would
expect us to rather than working from
home that's my own view
when it comes to actual motion itself
it's something i would consider voting
for and i could be supportive of it if
it were amended now if it only included
lib dems
working from home
then you would find me voting for it so
maybe consider that
thank you chair
council hall
thank you councillor foster has um
talked about
a lot that i was going to say anyway but
um i mean like the government where
council shipment states the government
asking people to work from home but for
for the last nearly two years we've had
that situation
the government wants us to get back to
normal the government wants us to
people to start coming back to work and
i think as councillors we should be
setting an example as well we we should
be going to the office we're elected to
come to meetings uh we we know the
situation and hopefully once covid
passes and things do get back to normal
it is something that we should we should
be encouraging in setting an example um
about what one of the other things i was
going to say is as well about
rep residents um
what one of the time i mean
when
members of the public are here residents
who vote for us
it's usually uh one of the times they do
get to see us uh many times i've heard
from different residents and one one
said to me the only time we see a local
council is one month before the election
we don't see them three years or 11
months
apart from one month before the standing
and here is a chance for us to
allow residents to see us
now well i'm just i'm just mentioning so
i it is i i do think for coming to the
meetings is really important not just
for us not just for the council but also
for members of the public and residents
to see us
thank you council lewis
thank you very much indeed uh chairman
um this is an interesting debate i mean
i think over the course of the last
couple of years the way local government
works been completely transformed anyway
and i think the approach of working much
more in a hybrid manner is something
we'll see much more of in the future for
certain committees etc but i do think
it's absolutely right that for meetings
like councils and cabinets and so on
that we do get that opportunity to uh to
meet face to face and have those uh key
debates
i just wanted to touch on uh councillor
lillian the hearing issue i think he's
absolutely right i'm in the same same
boat as you know chairman and
the complete deafness in my left ear and
a partial hearing in my right i do
struggle with these and another
thing that i found is that the last
couple years has been quite
transformative to be able to plug your
ears in
my earphones into the equipment and
indeed these particular devices allow
that as well i believe i can see a um a
jack in here which would allow um
equipment to be uh to be plugged in
directly into these units which would
feed into the ear and um i do that at
the county council as well um but i do
understand that this room it doesn't
have a loop system in and i don't know
if there's a technical reason that this
room doesn't have a loop system it may
have been rectified recently but
it does okay so that's good to hear um
but all accommodation should be made um
to uh uh to accommodate and those that
do have those particular issues thank
you chairman
thank you council dale
thanks very much chad i won't um go into
too much detail because i think most of
the points have been covered um needless
to say i think i agree with the general
thrust of the the previous contributions
that um
it'd be very useful to have the
flexibility
as a council to be able to have virtual
meetings but there is a time and a place
for them uh and i think there are
certain meetings that are best done uh
in person and just to add a little bit
more to what council cupid said um the
government did uh did consult on this
topic last year there was a call for
evidence all of the noises that i'm
hearing suggest that the government
fully intends to introduce measures and
the flexibilities and it's simply a case
that sadly it requires uh primary
legislation it's got to be considered
against other uh legislative priorities
within the within the house commons um
but it's certainly an issue that we
regularly raise both myself and officers
uh through things like lga and the dcn
um you know any opportunity we we can we
do raise it
and all the noise suggests that
it will come forward
it's a matter of time and therefore i
don't particularly see that the merit in
writing a further letter uh but we will
you know gladly assure council that will
continue to raise it at every
opportunity with uh relevant uh you know
in relevant regional and national forums
thank you jeff
thank you
council hancock you wish to speak
thank you chair um it's it's not often i
found myself agreeing with councillor
renick but um
um today i do um and i think i think
it's important whilst not a pa
work um having this ability and this is
the key thing is an ability it's not
saying replace
um
physical meetings but to allow other
members to join from home i think is
important we've seen the leader today
who wasn't even able to recommend his
own motion
because
it's not permitted under current
legislation so i'm actually quite
surprised by his response to the truth
um
in terms of um
sorry i forget joe's surname
it's councillor birkin um 100
on paris we have a wheelchair user who
is elected in bad weather she can't get
out of the house
so
you need to have to have things like
this to actually increase proper
diversity so we are representing our
residents um i think council hall let
something slip there that he clearly
doesn't necessarily see all of his
residents i think across all of the
parties here there are a lot of members
who who are seen regularly by their
by their residents um yes it's nice to
get here
and do that but there are circumstances
that do prevent people we know from
later on on the agenda it's also going
to come up
and um i think uh i think it is
important and
i remember the last motion or one of the
last motions of the old council which
was actually put forward by the
conservative group
and
that was about continuous improvement
and making sure that we took these steps
and we did them proactively and i know
there's been a change of leadership in
in the conservative group but it would
have been so much better to see the
current leadership
taking that forward and and respecting
what they voted for and what actually i
think everyone else in this council
voted for at the time it was one of
those rare consensus
so uh i think we we should be moving it
and i think we should be doing it
proactively not just sitting and waiting
for for westminster to follow
thank you council shipman thank you
chair um yeah i mean
councillor lilly's issue it complains
about every meeting and we still put him
in the back of the room i don't
understand why he's not at the front of
the room where we're it's closer to
where most people are talking throughout
the meeting so that's i found that
bizarre i think officers need to address
that asap to be honest because it is
getting a bit kind of tiresome here in
every meeting
um but in terms of the actual motion
it does surprise me because we've had
this we've had the same debate in viper
and all leader and all group leaders
have gone yep we need it yes we need to
do it and i think if we could all vote
it through and have this consensus
rather than just the conservative group
speaking to whoever it's speaking to
and
then the leader um council dale can go
and say our council across all the
groups wants to see this like i said
it's not prescriptive we can apply it as
and when depending on what meetings we
want i'll probably still be coming to
this meeting as much as i can um but i
totally understand that other counselors
have got accessibility issues like say
child care and uh come on i mean it's
not a hard motion to vote for if it
really is really going to kill you to
vote for writing a letter i think that
when we talk about playing politics in
this chamber i think um that's the
biggest
example of it
thank you it's been moved and seconded
then all those in favor of the motion
please show your hands
all those against
the motion is lost
however i think a number of points have
been raised through that debate that i
can see the monitoring officer taking
careful note um there does have to be a
reasonable adjustment and a number of
comments that
all sides should support and will do and
due courses recommendations are sorted
out about how we can improve access full
stop
and there's somebody who's an advocate
for
the deaf community i'm really pleased
that the bsl act is very close to
fruition and i've campaigned for a long
time for access for the deaf community
which is non-existent in the local
government
put in
yeah so uh next motion then counselor
hancock over to you
thank you chair again this one is is
written in the spirit of continuous
improvement so i suspect like the last
one it's going to fall
but i think it's important that we
acknowledge that things went wrong i
also think it's important that we
acknowledge the hard work
that our refuse collectors do and the
very challenging conditions that we have
in northeast derbyshire which are very
different
to what we have in the borough which is
often thrown at us um i i did um email
um correspond with uh with councillor
cupid and she has promised me that this
is going to be looked into but i think
we need a commitment so again it's for
proactive commitment to make sure
that we don't have a repetition of the
situation that arose this year
um leaving people for three weeks
without a black bean collection
yeah it may even have been four at some
points um
the teams work incredibly hard it wasn't
a
an issue with the refuse collectors
themselves it was a planning issue it
was a logistical issue um and we need to
we need to address that but we need to
make sure
that we we actually accept ownership of
that that yes it went wrong
and yes we're definitely going to put it
right and
make sure we do
i'll second that chair
it's robbery of my only question in that
bit right so
we'll just seconded any uh comments or
questions
council cupid
thanks sharon and thank you councillor
hancock for raising i think what as
you've said is an important issue and i
think this is a good opportunity to try
and explain and debate what happened
with the bing collections over christmas
uh and more widely you know in terms of
how we plan and logistics um as you said
from my response to you uh a few i think
it's about a month ago
and as i've said to viper members and
quite a few other members and residents
who've raised this issue with me um i do
understand sharing and i take on board
the concerns expressed by some families
over the christmas period with
collections this year and i committed to
review and try to prevent this in future
years
which with offices we've already done
and have been doing with darren and
steve
um so just to firstly look back at this
year i have to know it was a really
difficult and unique set of
circumstances that led to the longer
collection times faced by some
because of the ways the bank holidays
fell um to maintain collections over
christmas week we'd have had to compress
an already very packed um and tight
usual five-day service into three days
at a time when the transfer and tip
stations have shorter opening hours over
christmas and when there was a really
significant predicted risk of high
absences due to covered or winter
illnesses sadly those absences did
indeed transpire um due to the new
covert variant and at times during the
first few weeks of the new year we had
up to 20 refuse staff off
which is quite significant and then we
had a little bit of snow thrown in as
well
um so with that i just want to i know
council adele has already done it and i
know you've done it council hancock but
i want to offer my thanks to all those
who volunteered to help maintain
services uh and to all our refuge
drivers loaders and street scene staff
who go above and beyond on a day-to-day
basis and i think provide a really good
service throughout the year
particularly when faced with the sort of
natural and day-to-day challenges that
come from frontline services you know
quite often i see those
and i think we do have to recognize that
as a council we have maintained services
throughout the pandemic um when other
areas have had quite severe difficulties
and disruption that we've seen
nationally
um and i just want to say once you get
behind the collections it is very
difficult to catch up and there was a
high risk that would have happened over
the christmas period if we'd have done
that indeed other councils who did
continue collections over those three
days had that exact problem and then had
to suspend services um sheffield
chesterfield amber valley and derbyshire
dales and some of those are only just
catching up a month later now
um i do want to just say um in terms of
i know this isn't a claim that you've
made councillor hancock but i just
wanted to clarify comments that there
was a decision to benefit one part of
the district because that's factually
incorrect as the north calendar has had
similar issues in the past i don't
believe early collections really help
with christmas waste and i just wanted
to highlight to the chamber that weights
you know rubbish weights particularly
recycling have been more than double
across the district since recite since
christmas which is unprecedented um and
we have also from a health and safety
point of view which i know is in your
motion we've put on extra services where
possible to reduce bin and wagon weights
uh to you know to make sure that doesn't
have an impact on staff so looking
forward i do understand the difficulties
of the christmas period and the other
factors that i've outlined and i
reiterate what i've said to you in terms
of wanting to mitigate it in future
in terms of what we're doing we've
looked at next year and it won't happen
because the way they fall we've got
plans in place to maintain collections
over the jubilee bank holidays which are
a bit strange this year and with
officers we are also starting to look at
the current collection rounds
particularly where there's been
significant housing growth but we won't
get into that today
routes are getting really tight in the
south so we do need to carefully manage
that so it's not going to happen quickly
we've got to make sure we don't make it
worse but we're looking at also looking
ahead to the new national waste
legislation which may change collections
in terms of food waste and recycling so
whilst i agree with the points of this
motion i just can't support it today as
i don't think it factors in the
complexities of collections and some
other changes that are coming through i
do apologize for any inconvenience that
residents felt and i want to reiterate
the commitment that i've made as cabinet
member to do everything i can to make
sure all collections are as close to
fortnightly as possible and to review
the wider calendar to facilitate that
thank you chair
thank you council
barker yeah thank you chair thank you
charlotte for that and i appreciate the
difficulties that that's happened you
know we're a one-off i know we explained
it at the bar for meeting
what happened and you've just reiterated
that and cheerio and
i'd say like to thank all the the the
staff for doing you know over christmas
uh we we are going to sort of vote
for this motion uh but i accept what
you've said that you will try your best
to not it won't happen again and look at
things prior to the christmas period and
all that sort of stuff but
it's just so to put it on record that at
least we're gonna try his best and also
there's a caveat in this
uh that
let's not forget the the dustbin men
need holiday as well as uh so
you know there's a there's a solution to
this you just make a work over christmas
but i don't think that's the way forward
either so
uh you know i i don't want to sort of
commit to anything like that i think the
bin men are fully deserve the the
christmas holidays like everybody else
so
don't let's uh throw the baby out with
the bathwater as they say
is that appropriate
well bin men certainly wasn't it's
refuse collectors
council renek
i do apologize for the refuge
yeah i was quite surprised at this
motion because actually in 30 years near
that i've lived uh i can account for
the amount of times my bin's been missed
i think we have an exceptional service
as a county councillor responsible for
waste
cabinet member i am i can tell you now
we we our district is superbly compared
with other parts of the country and even
in derbyshire in terms of the weights
collect and you also have to bear in
mind that you know the waste when it
leaves here we've had extra services put
on i thought the christmas service was
was a really really really great idea
but then we've got waste transfer
systems at county to manage as well and
you know they store up and there's a
risk in that i can't support the motion
because actually against all perceived
guidance and wisdom at the moment around
uh carbon reduction and uh helping our
environment so actually we're wanting
actually smaller bins that hold the
whole slim bin we talked about slim bins
that was such reduced waste
and and also at defra i really hate to
point this out to anybody who's not read
the latest consultation is there is a
move to actually go to three weekly
collections
to actually reduce waste and and so from
from my point of view it's incumbent us
all to get along towards the waste
hierarchy of you know
sort of like reducing using recycling
before we get to energy and landfill but
i do think that um well there's specific
problems in certain parts of areas and i
noticed that um council hancock's motion
actually mentioned about certain certain
um of our residents might have struggled
to get to uh recycling centres and don't
forget at the moment if you go shopping
most supermarkets have basically cycling
um and i think perhaps the going forward
it's looking at helping those who really
can't get their way to cycle it's
uncomfortable to get our own way to
recycled above and beyond the the
facilities provided by um our district
and uh so i was going to say thank you
to our our bin service i think his
exceptional service we get
council hall
thank you chair uh councillor renning's
thought stolen part of my thumbnail this
time but in just in reference to
councillor hancock's motion the third
point down that it does talk about that
many residents have only a 180 liter
household waste bin now
now it's something that's been looked at
pro i guess not just by our council but
but by other councils and the amount of
uh waste that is produced and the amount
of waste the carbon footprint i guess
and trying to reduce it and i think some
councils have found that when they
provide
excessively large bins the bins are then
filled with other things like diy
material and building material and
things like that so even though he's put
we we only have a 180 league to
household bins i think for us as a
council and members of the public
i guess it's sufficient
god's sake so anyway thank you
council lewis
thank you chairman just a brief point i
think the other aspect of this that
we're missing and perhaps all to be
thinking about as well is the power of
the consumer in terms of
going to the shops and buying items
which are uh um superbly well wrapped
shall we say in uh in plastics etc etc
we've all bought home um our shopping
and then decanted it all and when you've
unwrapped it and you've got um half of
its waste you know um that's that's
that's that's another important
consideration we need to we need to uh
sort of get in there and use our buying
power as an organization as well and
perhaps use a little less single-use
plastic as well um in the future might
be the way forward um chairman but i do
believe actually it's possible for
residents to re uh to request a second
recycling bin um in certain
circumstances if they uh if they got
that amount of way so let's not forget
that as well
any other comments on council burkin
thank you chad just a a a quick question
is there a is there still a legal
uh limit on how long pins can go without
being collected
many years ago i was involved with the
bin men as they were then and there was
a legal requirement on that specific
time
is this something like that now with the
three weeks that councilor renix
talking about would that
go beyond any legal requirements
any other comments or questions
if not come to you council shipment
thank you chair um without trying to
replace the cabinet member for waste
collections uh there's other options
around it isn't it because
one of our policies is that we don't
collect bags that are next to bins
which has been a big issue so when
residents are coming to me saying can
will will the waste collectors take bags
of the salad bins we could have a policy
that said yes there's councils that
don't even have any bins they actually
just purely take bags of rubbish so i
don't understand this it can't possibly
be a health and safety issue around it
because they get around it somehow so
perhaps that's a way in which residents
can at least know that the rubbish is
going to get emptied at some point
um because
like i said when i've got when i've been
to street scene the answer was nay you
we're not collecting any bags out the
side of a bin
and i think that that's a problem isn't
it especially when we've got four weekly
collections at christmas
you can come to you counselor hancock
for writing reply
thank you chair and thank you to
councillor cupid for her response i i
think it would be nice to to actually
just put something on for the public and
actually formally do it and so i'm
disappointed that you can't um support
it and the the only real thing that i
picked up
in response to councillor hall with
regards to 180 litre bins the big issue
that you have with those is actually it
shifts the balance of of um the central
distribution and actually if you've got
the same amount in a 240 liter and then
180 billion the 180 bin seems heavier so
that's a much tougher workload on the
refuse collectors i'll make sure i use
the right turn
um but yeah i mean the key thing is our
refuse collectors did a brilliant job
and and yes we got the unusual
circumstances but i think it still was a
scheduling issue and that was at the
crux of it because they did an
absolutely fantastic job in picking up
the stuff that was missed and shorter
daylight hours means it's tougher
working hours anyway so it was the
scheduling where it fell down and that's
what we need to try and address
thank you chair
thank you well it's been moving seconded
all those in favor of the motion please
show your hands
all those against
any abstentions
the motion has been lost
so much item 14 i move
thank you it's not it's not school
council foster
[Laughter]
see you soon
so uh i move that the public be excluded
from the meeting during the discussion
of the following item of business to
avoid the disclosure to them of exempt
exempt information as defined in
paragraphs one two and three part one of
schedule 12a to the local government act
1972 as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006. do you have a secondary
thank you
all those in favor
anyone against any abstentions
that's it so we're now moving into
excluded
section so item
you